الخبر ابرز مشاهدينا الساعات الماضيه هو
الشلل اللي صاب حركه الطيران في امريكا
بشكل كلي بسبب عطل تقني فاداره الطيران
الفيدرالي اعلنت عن خطا تقني عطل 12000
رحله ووقفت كل الطيران في الاجواء واعلنت
السماح للطائرات بالهبوط فقط ووقف اي
اقلاع البيت الابيض اكد انه للان ما في اي
دليل على انه الموضوع هو هجوم سبراني
وللان لا زال سبب الهجوم بصراحه مشغول
طبعا خبر مثل هذا الفيديو دقائق
على تويتر شفنا اختصار اداره الطيران
الفدرالي متصدره ترند في امريكا وفي
العالم ومن بعد الخبر للان مثل ما واضح
امامكم زياده مهوله في البحث عن كلمه همم
اف اي اي او اداره الطيران الفيدرالي على
جوجل وحول العالم
الطيران طبعا رجع لا طبيعته الموضوع
بالنسبه للمشاهد العادي يمكن غريب كثير
ومش مفهوم حقيقه وعلشان نحاول نفهم طلبنا
من الطيار صديقنا الكابتن ليث الرشيد يفسر
لنا وهذا كان رده
الطيران في الولايات المتحده
الخلل هو بسبب نظام يسمى النوتيلا
نظام اخبار
الطيارين ورجال الطيران باي اعمال صيانه
او اغلاق او تغيير على المدارس والمطارات
داخل الولايات المتحده هذا نظام هو نظام
التقنيه همم ممكن من النظره الثانيه هيك
الموقع الالكتروني حاليا
تعطل لذلك لم تستطيع المطارات والمدارج في
الولايات المتحده الاخبار باي اعطال اي
تغييرات اي حركه تبيعيه في اي تدريبات
عسكريه في الاجواء او اعطال في الاضاءه او
في انظمه الاقلاع والهبوط داخل المطارات
نفسها لا يوجد علاقه بهذا النظام في
الطائرات نفسها
ولكن السبب ايقاف حاله الطيران هو الطيار
لا يستطيع همم قيام رحلته الا قبل ان
يتاكد من ان المطار في وجهته
عامل بشكل همم فني همم وامن
وتعرف عن ذلك يتم عن طريق الدخول على هذا
النظام سواء الطيار يدخل الى هذا النظام
ويمر الى المطار والمطارات التي يريد
استخدامها ويتاكد من همم فعاليتها
همم في حاله هذا العطل همم لم يستطيعوا
الطيارين الدخول الى هذا النظام بسبب تعطل
ولذلك تم ايقاف حركه الطيران والان بدات
تعود تدريجيا الى وضعها السابق
العطل الفني همم كما قلت وهو قد يكون بسبب
هكر قد يكون بسبب تعطل نظام يكون في نفسه
او الاقمار الصناعيه والاتصالات لحد الان
لم يعرف السبب اا ولكن بداوا في اصلاح
وبداوا في
تحرك داخل المطارات هو اثر فعلا على
المطارات والرحلات الداخليه داخل الولايات
المتحده او الرحلات الخارجيه القادمه الى
الولايات المتحده اذا كان هناك رحله ذاهبه
الى خارج الولايات المتحده لا تتاثر لانه
بطبيعه الحال المطارات خارج الولايات
المتحده اخبرت بجميع معلوماتها على هذا
النظام ولم يكن هناك اي خبر فهو
عطل فني اثر على حركه الداخليه ليس بخطير
من ناحيه امان على الطائرات ولكن
تمت السيطره عليه واتوقع خلال ساعه
القادمه ستعود الحركه